here at eight news now
we span the globe bringing you the wide
world of athletic competition
for example
this oh no and it looked like if there
was any wind at all it was going to get
that push it needed to get over but
just fell short just missed a two-run
home run right there
brings up eric corral he drives one deep
to center no we need a [ __ ] burner
all right so let's be clear here that
center fielder is someone you know very
well i married that man this is the
premier wiffle ball league here in town
yeah it's actually huge they they air on
twitch i mean they have live streaming
yeah
he signed autographed wiffle balls for
fans and other stuff oh my goodness
where is it where are they playing oh
you know what it's uh
it's someone's personal property
it looks like somebody's yard yeah
they've developed the entire field in
this in this yard it's kind of in
southwest las vegas
and that was your man he's okay i think
minus the sunglasses he came up
and i'm good you're welcome have a good
memorial day weekend okay we'll see you
on monday